well with the brexit deadlock ongoing
there's growing concerns that other
issues aren't getting the attention that
they deserve and it's
certainly something that i felt when i
traveled to birmingham earlier this week
to sit down with one of the country's
most outspoken mps
the southeast of the city is the
constituency of birmingham
yardley multicultural urban 35
of children here are classed as living
in poverty in the brexit referendum
every one of the seats four wards voted
to leave the eu
stoke not being dictated by european so
many like uh
they make all the rules and things yet
we're able to follow
a lot of the mps their constituents
actually voted to come out
and they're voting to stay in so who do
they who do they represent themselves or
their
people you know there are a lot more
issues going on right now and
uh it sounds like everything's kind of
being put on hold because of brexit you
know just happens if
there's a few more police on the beat
with that i mean years ago there's
always police walking about but
you can hardly see one even if you have
to fire them at six hours for them to
come
that's also how i think because she'll
concentrate on that a bit more
get the country first before we think
about drexel
the message on this high street was that
people want politicians to get on with
brexit now
there are no surprises there we hear
that message a lot but what struck me
was that people were saying it not
because they're bored of brexit
but because they're worried that because
of brexit other important issues are
being ignored
the member of parliament is labour's
jess phillips who backs a second
referendum
we arrived at her office prepared to do
an interview on the intricacies of
brexit
but after spending a few hours here how
are you my love
you look quite well oh no don't say that
listening
to complex constituency cases there's a
chance
but i'm not going to promise you
anything because i don't want to be
another person who's let you down on
everything from housing to prisons to
immigration
it felt right to start in a different
place the entire bandwidth of everything
that happens in my constituents lives
has been entirely taken away and there
are real
stories real lives real problems in our
country
that should be front page news in
ordinary times
and are now just being completely
forgotten i mean what kind of thing are
you talking about
so i mean as you've seen why we've been
here this morning
we've got really really difficult and
complicated immigration cases
not dissimilar to windrush where my
constituents are not able to
their children are able to get educated
because of failings in the home office
we've got issues really serious housing
issues
where in my constituency at any one time
there are 30
40 families living in one room
with no access to cooking facilities
sometimes not even washing facilities
for years people are living like this
for years and
our local schools all around us are
having to
shorten their hours lessen their number
of teachers
it is we are at breaking point here and
i don't feel like theresa may
understands that and she stands in front
of me at the dispatch box and tells me
i'm letting the people down
she wants to come and sit here for her
inheritance and i guess what theresa may
might say is that she's the one who's
trying to get on with it and that it's
mps who are stopping her
from moving on except that that's just
simply not true in that she's trying to
get on with it she's trying to get on
with what she deems the best option
she deems that from a point of view of
no experience of what it's like
to live around here for example she
doesn't understand that a really bad
deal for the economy
in her constituency in windsor
probably won't affect people that badly
but i
people where i live are living on the
edge
and anything that pushes them
even a fraction will push them over the
edge most people here
the biggest employer is either the nhs
or
jaguar land rover the car industry both
are threatened by a bad brexit deal it's
been quite an eye opener actually for me
spending the morning in your
constituency office just seeing the
number of people coming through the door
the kind of thing that they're talking
about
the challenges that they face in their
daily lives
you seem really quite angry when i come
here
by the end of every day i am exhausted
with vicarious trauma for the lives of
my constituents
i mean obviously it's not all bad but
the people i see are the people in
crisis and i see them
all day every day i am so angry that
their lives matter so little
in your constituency all four wards
voted
to leave the eu and you support the
second referendum
nobody who voted leave here has a
massive go at me i mean
you get the odd one
that's not what they're saying to me
they trust me
to try and do the best thing for them
not all of them but no
constituency is full of people who
universally support the member of
parliament
i mean my constituents don't all think
the same thing they didn't all vote
leave because
they hate immigrants they didn't all i
mean lots of them are immigrants
they didn't all vote leave because they
wanted to take back control they didn't
all vote leave because they hated
the customers union they all have
different reasons
the vast majority of people voted leave
because
they wanted to show the system that they
weren't happy and who can blame them
who can blame them but when look my
constituents
are lots of them may well disagree with
my position the position that i have
come to i didn't get there easily
but the position i've come to is that
parliament can no longer deal with this
and they may well disagree with me and
that is democracy
and if they disagree with me they don't
have to vote for me
and i may lose my job but frankly their
jobs are more important
at the minute um jeremy corbyn and
theresa may are having talks
trying to thrash out some kind of
compromise would you like to see a
situation where
they come to a deal or would you see
that as the labour party facilitating
a conservative i mean i think it is uh
oh far too little too late and they
should have been talking a long time ago
and actually i blame theresa may
entirely for that
um but so you hope they come to a deal i
i hope that they come to a deal but the
deal
that i feel they have to come to
whatever
machination it is of what the actual
deal with the european union
could be negotiated is that i think it
has to go back to the people
that's the red line for me i'm afraid to
say and theresa may gets to have redline
so i'll have a few
so even if for example the con
tourism may shifted her position all the
way to say that she's happy to sign up
to a permanent customs union
that wouldn't be enough for you you'd
say that would have to go to a public
vote
no yeah i mean that wouldn't be enough
for me do you think there's much of a
frustration
towards lame but for not having a
clearer position yes for playing
politics totally i think that there is
frustration for labour
i'm not i can't say that the sort of my
neutral over the
um customs union is a massive concern to
my constituents if i was
they speak of little else but the
customs union in birmingham yardley
is it is there a feeling that labour's
playing politics
i i think that there is a bit of a
feeling of that i think that
uh certainly within the labour party
membership and the and the broader
country that
i think that it hasn't been clear
actually from the beginning
and i think that actually that position
was understandable to a point because we
do have the most leave and the most
remained constituencies
i'm not going to sit here and pretend
that jeremy corbyn was put in a really
easy position and he just botched it
but i think that there was a point where
the sort of fudge and the different
briefing whether it's barry gardner
comes out and says one thing here
starmer comes out and says another
i think it's been quite confusing for
journalists it's been quite confusing
for uh members of parliament members of
the labour party and members of the
public
um so i think they're at a point
what you need to do is show some real
leadership and say look
i know not everybody's going to agree
with this but this is our position
because at the moment we're sort of
irritating everyone
and pleasing no one triangulating when
done well i suppose
makes gives a little bit of something to
everyone at the moment all we're giving
to everybody is a bit of annoyance
in uh an interview with the times um
famous interview
um you said that you felt
exhausted that you felt that you were at
the end of the road
for all of it is that how you still feel
i mean
when i was interviewed for the times was
literally the moment after i had
shouted at theresa may because there
were people in my constituency being
moved out of
the hotel rooms that they were having to
live in because crafts was coming
and the dog show so dogs
literally trumped my homeless
constituents
in those weeks i'm faced with something
like that
i was so i and i still i remain
so angry at
the complete lack of political will to
try and help
people's actual lives and to recognize
why we've ended up in this situation
and i suppose when i say i was at the
end of the line
i feel constantly like we are failing
the political class now i really believe
in parliament i really believe in the
labour party i really believe
in all of that but my faith is being
challenged because i feel like the
political class
is looking after itself a little bit
sometimes at the moment
i'm sick of that being the thing when
there's people in my constituency
who are homeless and being replaced by
miniature schnauzers
some people took that about you saying
about and being at the end of the road
is being the end of the road for the
labour party yeah is that right
i mean i think actually in the the weeks
since i did that interview
my i have a um a reignited
um flame for the labour party
that has come about because we are very
much in parliament at the moment we are
a united unit with a common purpose
and it's it's not factional it's not
left right who
loves it
but within those different factions that
have always existed
the the there's crossover so
at the moment you've got me and clive
lewis working together hand in hand to
try and achieve something that we think
is best for the country
and actually there is a sort of purpose
and i think that
if people like me leave the labour party
which you know i have to say
it's not always easy when i mean i've
got people from the
labor party who are currently under a
police investigation for threatening to
kill me
why do you think you become such a
lightning rod
for this kind of abuse um because i say
what i think
and because i can't be controlled and
like anyone who wants to
control you so there's a lot of in
politics there is a lot of people who
want to control you and make you say
certain things whether that's your party
whether uh that's the your local
membership and i have to say i don't
have a problem in my local membership
they are lovely
kind people and reasonable and we have
reasonable conversations
but if you can't control what a person
says
with the normal mechanisms of like well
we'll get rid of you
the threats the even the nice approach
if you can't
make them say exactly what you want and
they want me to say that basically
jeremy corbyn is the best thing since
large bread
um if they can't make you
like in any power and control model
they violence is the way to control an
uncontrollable person um and so that's
why i became a lightning rod because i
say what i think
and also i'm a woman that doesn't help
that's never
also they can i think that they consider
that i am
they have to intimidate me and try and
make the things that i say not credible
they're constantly trying to
there's a propaganda war that goes on
that tries to take the credibility of
your voice away
it's because they're worried that people
listen to me you said that about um
being a woman you've also said that
marxism has always had a problem with
women because class is everything
yeah do you think that comes into it
it's not that definitely there's a blind
spot maybe
there is a problem um where the left has
always been
actually the sort of beacon of hope for
women's rights
there is a section of the left that
thinks that basically
classes everything and sometimes there
is this sort of like
we are there to be helped rather than to
be agents of our own
change um but i mean i i'm happy to say
that that is rare
but it's still definitely there that
that's that sort of purist marxist view
that rich or poor is all that matters
yeah
yeah so would you like the next leaders
to be a woman yes of course
absolutely lately yeah i mean i think it
would be a massive embarrassment
amongst other things if if the labor
party once again
fails to um have
a woman leader some people would like
you to stand i i recognise that some
people would like me to stand
and you never know maybe one day at the
moment i feel so
tired i can't think of a job i'd least
like to have uh
than to be the leader of the labour
party it doesn't look like much fun
at the moment jeremy corbyn and theresa
may seem quite
stressed yeah i do both seem to have
aged quite a lot
over the period um yeah they do seem
quite stressed
i imagine actually i can't imagine what
it's like when they're chatting with
each other but i imagine they probably
could get on quite well
really they've got a lot of shared
stress they could like give each other a
bit of a therapy session
do you think that's what's going on in
dallas yeah really they're like oh god i
haven't slept for weeks to recently
she's like oh
i've missed all of the recent episodes
of fleabag i really need to catch up
uh jessica looks like you're very very
worried